let's bring our guest and he's here and
I smells really good Bruce Bochy smells
good we got Bruce Buffer we have mark
Normand coming in later and we have
ebony Kate Williams from Fox News coming
in later we're gonna start with Bruce
Buffer early yes well it's it's a big
weekend for Bruce hello Bruce
how's the gone Bruce welcome to the show
smell very good and you're in a
three-piece suit early in the morning
it's um a very impressive yeah yeah it's
what I do Jim but honestly I'm a
bathing-suit by day tuxedo by night kind
of guy
oh hey thinks you I'm surfer brother oh
is that right she's still so yeah not
with no ACL on my name all right you
hurt your leg that's right yeah how is
it I remember that yeah the night of
your show I'm I'm rehabbing I'm going
without the operation rehabbing three
hours a day okay can you tell people how
you hurt it Bruce's doing I can tell you
I watched it well you did watch Oh God I
watched the video and it was it was so
funny to watch you Bruce like you
realized right away that something was
wrong right and you were like [ __ ] it I
got a power through this song yeah I
still got to perform he's performing
what song was it it was rebel yell by
Billy Idol and was karaoke yet note it
was lips lips it's a even better so then
and now I've got this whole affliction
towards lipstick if I get a called
mellow Cool J it's gonna be I'm sorry
all your grace I gotta say no it's too
dangerous
yes - it's too dangerous I jumped at the
top of it and what happened is when you
watch the video Billy Idol jumps to the
top and you know I can jump spin around
kick in the head which I can't do right
now but I jumped and it did a little
jump and I came down in the stage at the
Lagasse was in sections and the left
section kind of gave a little bit and
caused my foot to slip in like my Reebok
shoe Thank You Reebok and um the knee
just buckled and it blew and then I fell
like about 50 seconds into it the knee
just gave away uh but I'm like the show
must go on it was a three-minute
rendition I did the guitar so the whole
bit and then I went down an Emer on next
morning they go you're a CEO is gone
you seem shaken on the knee out he's
trying to just kind of walk it off I go
that was just kind of walk you walk it
on what but then you realize like not as
bad but you know when I was younger I
was kickboxing like crazy I'd you know
roll an ankle hurt the knee and shake it
off and get back in the fight you know I
guess that doesn't happen anymore you
passed 50 it's like forget that that's
not gonna happen no but it was I was fun
watching you the next night - cuz Bruce
to our being Matt we're out and um they
just doing the podcast and we come in
that night to do we're doing a night
taping and they're like yeah Bruce
Buffer canceled because he hurt himself
in John Jones's out of the fight so you
guys just talk now it was really a talk
about that that was a bad one you didn't
like that one no I didn't weren't
prepared it was not that was a rough one
I felt horrible I was okay because I
told them I said guys the knees hurt I
said get me over to the show and there
was the PR people that made me not go I
was ready to go for you Dana Dana text
uh tweeted out a video of me falling
down on the stage and he goes not this
was after Jones fight was announced or
his cancellation and he said this is
what my last 24 hours has been like yeah
not now here's what I'm worried about
guys yeah when I did the biggest show in
Toronto in front of 55,000 people
yeah years ago when Jake Shields fought
George st. Pierre that night I blew my
ACL on my right knee
announcer George st. Pierre in the
Octagon was he and this is what people
who too aren't familiar with what you do
may not understand like Bruce Buffer
obviously is the ring announcer for the
UFC but like two gunmen sir
yes I'm sorry yes the Octagon announcer
for UFC but he's far and away the most
active and animated announcer that
there's literally ever been thank you
you know the 360 is your is your
trademark your your in the air
you're jumping you're an athletic it's
developed answer it hasn't always been
like that like I was watching you in
less I was watching an old Don Frye
fight mm-hmm and can I see you do it one
o'clock in the morning when you have no
love in your life [ __ ] fight pass
that's after we put away the vastly had
the Kleenex right before she came over
and I was watching I didn't know you had
been announcing from like UFC ten on and
it was so funny just to watch you it was
much mellower too much more uh yeah it's
fun to watch now I enjoy this much more
oh thanks I appreciate that Jim but you
know you know the thing is that
announcers concentrate on their voice
and people ask me what I am they I say
well I'm a performer you know I'm
actually a fan first announcer second
you know however you want to put it but
back in those days and you know I
managed my brother the legendary Michael
buffer for 25 plus years now and if
anybody could have copied an announcer
it would have been me but I never wanted
to be Frank Sinatra
here right so I wanted at my own style
and I told myself that when I get into
this I'm gonna develop my own style and
if I don't then I'm going to get out of
it because I just don't want to be one
of those guys that grabs a paycheck and
a nice seat and watches a fight so it's
not my thing
sure my thing is the fights of course
but I want to do so much more as
promoter than sports a little bit anyway
getting back to it eventually
instead of standing Center you ever see
Butch Cassidy the Sundance Kid with
Robert Redford and Paul Newman I don't
remember but I did see it well there's a
scene in there when he's there shooting
and and red and Brett Redford is just
standing there and trying to shoot and
he can't hit the broad side of a barn
and he looks at Newman he goes can I
move and all of a sudden moves right and
then he's hitting everything right
inside me was like I needed to move I
don't want to stand Center I needed to
move I gotta get I got to introduce
these fighters away I would want to be
introduced if I was fighting I know what
it's like to stand across and go
toe-to-toe with somebody so I wanted to
throw my whole passion into it and
that's what started to evolve when I
realized I can do this
I can break out and do that you don't
just be a carbon copy of the but like
you don't have your own thing that's
kind of close to his you want to be -
yeah you want to go like let's get ready
to fight this is just no good let's get
ready to is not in my vocabulary when
you start doing that when you start
spinning around and stuffing it really
animated does to the people running the
promotion do they like that or they go
on like brus like this it's not your
show like what are you doing I probably
shocked a few people the show is not
about me by all standards Sharon I am
there to enhance the moment for the
fighters and the fans and that's my job
and that's the way I look at it so I've
never had anybody say anything to me if
anything is like an you do a 360 can you
do another one I go no it's one and done
you know that's how you make things work
you know what's interesting actually
that makes me think about the fact that
and it could be your style I don't know
but when Jim we took him to Wrestlemania
a couple years ago and his big criticism
was he's like I like the show I like the
you know the over-the-topness but he
goes but there was something about the
announcing that just idea it felt like
it wasn't a big deal yeah because I
wasn't in the ring it was but it was
done before they walk in the ring and
I'm like you need an announcer in the
ring that's a part of it when the guys
are just standing there ready to fight
somebody getting you pumped up that's my
fit one um but it's one of my favorite
parts the fighters and [ __ ] saying
their names are like I'm just really
enjoying it yeah
getting all amped up yeah you like it
tell you what gets me after couple times
I've heard Jim after a big UFC I hear
him on a show and he's and he pays
homage to mean it's like wow you know
I'm like I'm like thank you Jim no it's
great very enjoyable so what were you
saying about about being in front of
55,000 people oh yeah let's see that was
the biggest show ever yeah and I forget
the number of it but uh I had rolled my
ankle of the week before I was actually
in a poker tournament I play a lot of
Poker and at the break I hit a dip in
the carp and rolled my ankle and I went
to going to the hospital because it
pulled off with blood and they had to
pull blood out of it Jesus I took third
in the tournament I want a bunch of
money that was great but I couldn't
stand on my foot for someone who's so
closely associated to a very dangerous
sport you get injured in silly ways yeah
I think is that I used to really fight
you know stand toe-to-toe and surf big
waves and all yeah I've been you know
knocked out and stuff like that but I've
never like torn tendons and broken bones
and I guess it happens after you passed
you know 40 or whatever I think no no
other announcer in history has ever
gotten hurt making an announcement on
the ring you're the first person to ever
get hurt me I mean on two body parts to
the UFC a face yells yah both ACLs to
you roll your ankle
okay I'll roll my ankle I couldn't stand
on my foot as of that Wednesday I
started to be able to stand on Thursday
now I take off for Canada biggest show
in the history I get out there my
adrenaline starts taking over I turn I
jump I spin I do all my normal stuff and
I never plan anything I never rehearse I
don't stand in the shower and go Chuck
Liddell you know as I'm washing my hair
I go out there I feel the energy the
crowd I feed off and I let it flow so
the show went great and then I go in
announce Georges st. Pierre and and I
get into his corner and you know George
rush and then he lunges out which he's
done every time and I bunnyhop back like
about a foot to half two feet which I've
done every time he's done it and it
didn't occur to me about my ankle when I
bunnyhop back my ankle wobble doesn't
hit the ground and when he exploded I
was like George rush say oh my god you
know and then I walked over to her Dean
and I put the microphone under his
armpit I've got my my octagon face on
and inside I'm going you mother-effer
you just blew your friggin knee yeah you
know and I get out of the Octagon and
John McCarthy says I think you just blew
your ACL and Stitch the cup man gives me
a bag of ice and my knees what my pass
bike is rolled up I got ice on my knee
on the
damn announcer I'm watching two great
warriors go at it what is wrong with
that picture yeah it was wrong how do
the fighters when you show up and you're
in the locker room or backstage or
whatever and you're nursing an injury
but it's from chopping back or it's from
like you know lip-synching to rebel yell
or whatever how do the fighters react to
you nursing your injuries you know
Rashad Evans called me like the next day
steep steep ami ochi was with me that
night and they're like you're just they
thought I was like a stud they thought
it was great
you know that I just even complained the
bottom line is is that no matter what
their thoughts are with all respect
these guys are fighters they're putting
their blood sweat and tears and their
lives on the line I'm the announcer the
show must go on I don't complain last
thing I'm gonna do is complain to a
warrior about my sore knee
are you still afraid are you comfortable
in your position you still get like that
I know I'm out soon like a Dior do you
always worry that you're gonna screw it
up or you like I'm here I'm not going
anywhere
I don't quite understand mean as far as
your job like are you comfortable in
your job I think Jim's because from our
perspective Jim and I are similar in
that way where we're constantly I'm
never comfortable where I am I'm afraid
I'm gonna get fired constantly oh no I
don't worry about that at all no you're
confident in your ability like this is
like you know what you you're the best
at what you do I well I mean I'll never
say that because that if I said that I
can sound a little cocky and I'm I like
to be very humble about everything I
walk around with strong confidence am I
not seen that way you know sometimes but
I understand where you're coming from
with the recent buyout of the UFC a lot
of people worried about that but I've
been in the Octagon now I celebrated my
20th year anniversary
back in February my first show was UFC
eight and Bayamon Puerto Rico and I'm
then UFC 10 with Don Frye and 13 on was
when I did all the shows from that point
so my thing is and and I teach I do
motivational speeches to entrepreneurs
and business owners I was just in
Florida yesterday doing one with John
Travolta and 50 cent Wow yeah and this
big thing they had down there so one of
the things I instill in teaching people
that are entrepreneurs is you got to
have confidence if you walk in the room
and you do your job with fear that you
might not have the job the next day no
offense guys but you're not going to do
your best job you know you need to be in
this I'm the best at what I do or
another way to
say is I'm going to give the best that I
can give and this is my job and this is
what I set out to do my pet you have
passion for what you do and believe in
the stability of your situation that's
not probably walk in we look each other
and go your average that helps us or you
can we just start guys are far from
average okay good I did I just tell you
that it'll help you out thank you very
much I'm a huge fan you know that yeah
next time I say you next time you say
your average I'm gonna say you are too
and you're like that's not Bruce Buffer
thanks as well as it was just remember
when you tell him your average there's
no girls in the room you don't to
confuse their perception that's very
good no they are understandable average
what was that did you spend time with
revolta no actually he was coming on
after a left had to catch a plane to New
York I was literally just I was like it
was like ships in the night ships in the
night passing yeah yeah they a Calvin
Klein down there that a bunch of speak I
met him at I did an interview after he
did it somewhere like with the same
people for a different thing who drove
out there Calvin Klein and he was uh I
don't know if he's straighter yeah I've
heard make sure I've heard yet both what
both but the will over his assistant was
the guy he was with I never look at like
a man and go like I could [ __ ] marry
that man the best-looking human being
I've ever seen in my life
yeah maybe she's a sexual dude was no
but I wasn't Calvin Klein's assistant
his assistant it's like whoever this
person was I'm like this is probably the
most beautiful person I've ever seen in
my life
right right there's no there's no gender
role humiliating
yes a man to my genetic competition
there's nothing wrong with with
appreciating the beauty of another human
being male or female you know obviously
you know I know I know you're straight -
straight can be so kind of a narrow kind
of way yeah don't don't let those
thoughts confuse you as on saying like
like you know how you know how when
somebody with the you know the javelin
throw you know there's javelins they're
very like straight right yeah Jim is
like a javelin but like the one that
Lavar and Legos like went to the nerman
terrace it's wobbling it lands were
supposed to but you really have no clue
words you know exactly but yeah no I
didn't say anything to them I you know I
just we we've met and I just I just
crushed his face for a second I think I
weird about
how'd you get into the or how does one I
guess get into the motivational speaking
game because I've I've seen people do
that and there's that say it's a huge
business yeah it's a huge business and I
work with some key speakers but I've
always loved helping people better
themselves helping people make money
helping people be happy have a three
foot theory if I like right now if I can
do the show well enough to the you guys
you know everything goes great for you
you have good ratings it's successful
your paychecks cash I don't think about
myself I think about everybody else and
then comically I know it'll all come
back to me so I really get off being a
public speaker I've done it since my 20s
I own a nutritional company I wanted a
competition against the company called
Herbalife member Herbalife or
so I started a company called herbal
care with my partner and I used to
travel the country doing motivational
speeches teaching the benefits of
nutrition how to feel better or feel
great make money in the process you know
become a product of the products and
that's was the start of my whole
motivational one and I just got off on
seeing people happy and and when they
write back and say hey you know you
helped me I'm I'm feeling great I my
bank accounts bigger I'm making money my
organization is growing that I'll be the
first one always cash a paycheck on a
Monday trust me I'll be at the bank for
anybody yeah but I'm not about the
paycheck you know I like to enjoy what I
do and I love seeing people happy and if
I could have an effect on that a
positive effect then just I get off see
we're about the Paycheck like we look at
each other always sees dollar signs oh
yeah oh yeah I go Jim I hope the next
Bachelor super successful that's the
biggest thing I can tell you is that um
whether it's a girlfriend I'm dating or
you know whatever I love I'm passionate
I'm Italian maybe cuz my heritage
whatever but I like to have passion for
what I do and if I don't then you know
it's not there's nothing I want to do
what is your opening when you start I
could ever motivationally speak because
it would frighten me that would just not
move anybody like you know yes the
insecurities again absolutely
everybody's looking at me going he's a
failure while we they not to it so I
what do you motivate them to do like you
you would you like I said it's a roomful
of people you don't know like I know I
gotta go up there and [ __ ] around and
make them laugh but if you're motivating
how do you know you're motivating them
well you know all motivational speakers
whether you're Zig Ziglar from the past
or you're Tony Robbins or whatever a lot
of us you
in a way we're all kind of saying the
same thing we just say it in our own way
and the biggest thing I believe is a
motivational speaker and I teach
branding and marketing that's my main
thing is you know excitement about what
you do teach branding and marketing
because branding is my gig I'm a
marketer first and foremost but the
bottom line is that the people in the
audience get a positive effect from you
for one minute one hour one day or one
year you've done your job you know it's
up to them to take that what they get
from you and to make it work for them
you just have to firmly believe what
you're saying you know it to be true
yeah I I do not lie I'm the most honest
person in the world of course I could be
lying through my teeth telling you
that's right no lawyer would admit it
that's true yeah but I will tell you
that the reason I play poker is because
it's legal to lie at the poker table I
get my iOS out on the poker table you
can be my best friend I'm taking all
your chips right and I'll lie through my
teeth to get them and a bottom line so
you said you are you are a good poker
player that means you make a decent
amount playing it or now do you not do
it like from I play when I have time I
was voted card there's a card player
magazine is the biggest magazine and
website out there for poker players I
got voted the number 8 best celebrity
poker player in the world about five
years ago and Iommi was I'll tell you is
number one this will surprise you Gabe
Kaplan Welcome Back Kotter
now he did that professionally for years
uh yeah that's that that's not I've
heard for years he's a great didn't work
for Jack Ruby at one point too I don't
know you go in the sixty when he was
doing stand-up he did I think the guy
that shot Oswald yeah I think Gabe
Kaplan did one of his clubs in the 60s
really yeah I don't know why I've only
met Gabe a couple of times I've never
asked him you should know because I
don't know if that's like I love his in
the right age group for that so it's
like an [ __ ] just dating etiquette
the other the other guy's below me were
Tobey Maguire Ben Affleck Wow Jennifer
Tilly
so you have a good poke cider ups you've
a good poker face because whenever you
get like whatever there's a split
decision and you look at it you seem to
never give away who is about to win to
go yeah no I can I can you know that's
that's part of the the poker face helps
when I'm in the Octagon I mean sometimes
I get that decision from these guys is
like what yeah I've done the first one
to see beside the Commission and so you
have had that moment we are like to sit
you got to be kidding me were we
watching the same fight I can't begin to
tell you how many times and you guys
could name the fights you know there's
key fights have happened just in the
last couple years
but my job is on the messenger don't
kill the messenger I got to go out and
do my thing and then people say oh the
tweeted always standing be always stands
behind the winner dude I've got two
people to stand behind I mean I can only
switch up so many times sometimes I'm
behind the winner sometimes I'm behind
the loser
and then the key thing is to bring out
the drama when the decision comes out
you know what do you do
fits the week of a pay-per-view and you
wake up with a sore throat I've done the
show with laryngitis I've done with sore
throat 104 degree temperature blown out
back blown out knees
you know IV sauce a voice was gonna
crack though like if I had a sore throat
because if you have a sore throat you're
like I think I can get through it then
you yell your voice cracks and I mean
you're done well in the early days you
know singers they bring it from here
right okay then in the early days house
- yeah the chest that's why we're mine
comes from so I've learned it you learn
your tool you know you perfect your tool
right so in the early working on his
tool last night yes I was perfecting it
it's a life lot lifelong ambition isn't
it try to polish out the wrinkles
created like in the early days it was
the first Japan show rent or fog and I
would bring it from my throat I cracked
and and this is one of the most
embarrassing things I ever did was like
Randy Couture it went like that you know
all 25,000 people in the Japan arena
whatever it was but it was quite
embarrassing at that point so you just
used to learn how to perfect your art
you know like anything else it is I mean
announcing is not rocket science okay
but the trick is to make it look easy
you know and to do what you do and I
just try to just try to do what I can
do you get because you were you grew up
fighting mm-hmm so when you see like
does that I guess wouldn't be in you
maybe anymore but at first when you're
the announcer are you looking at the
fighters going like that's where I
should be
you know honestly if I was in my 20s
yeah training the way I was I know when
I was doing a lot of kickboxing I wanted
to have a professional fight just to say
I had a professional fight if I was back
in my 20s and like you know in the mid
90s when this was happening and I was
training I'm sure I would have had that
thought of ambition like a lot of guys
do whether I would have set out to do it
or not I don't know but the one thing I
do
as I understand fighters mentalities I
understand what it takes to be a fighter
it's the loneliest job in the world
because really bottom line when that
cage closes just you you know no matter
who your team is it's just you
so my respect for these great warriors
male and female both is what drives me
one of the many things that drive me to
do what I do to tree off travel and be
on the road for 40-plus weeks a year
doing UFC's and giving up and
sacrificing relationships and seeing my
family as much as I want to either you
know you're on the road yeah hey you
know there is a sacrifice in doing that
kind of stuff yeah I mean for me I have
no family so it's like I have my parents
I don't have any but you know anyway I'm
close to some yeah just me in the hotel
no different to my apartment leave me
alone make sure I'm looking at the right
back page city creating wrinkles in
hotel rooms all over the world do you
really do a wedding oh yeah no I do I
you know what it is on on my site I'm I
guess I got a plug Bruce Buffer comm the
fans go there and I have a special like
I've been paid ridiculous money to like
championship introductions but weddings
I've done over a couple hundred weddings
I did Michael Bisping wedding
I've actually married you know people
but I I record them walking into the
reception I'd love by the way to meet
Michael Bisping wife that's like really
like you can't leave work at work for
one day I can't have one day we got to
bring him you wanna see into the way
that he had to be talked into that yeah
I'll be like me being like just good
news Jim is gonna marry us like really
say I'm like well you know it's it's I
get if you go on YouTube and you put in
my name put of weddings you'll see where
they videotaped the recordings I've done
I've also done them in front of a green
screen so they can play them on their
video thing and the main thing is
introduce the wedding route party in you
know the bridesmaids the groom's play it
up and then the bride and groom come in
so and now you know walking down the
aisle of love forever and give them the
big big introduction I've done birth of
babies you know coming out now now oh
yeah like you're in the room as well I
mean those are script and I'll recorded
and they'll book though document the day
the birth of their child you know which
is which is it makes me feel really cool
what's the weirdest request you've
gotten you had to get some that you're
like I can't you know I get I I'll get
something
with curse words and it's just
disrespectful it's not who I am it's
like I have a problem cuz morality is
going to hell in a handbasket this
country's it is I don't want to cater to
that okay yeah so I'll say no to those
things so you don't want to like a guy
and his girlfriend and now inserting
himself into you well I could I could
actually do that in a way that it would
work right course right no problem the
winner not her I just don't want to be
in the room doing a live you know it's
okay yeah a gym would he'd love to be an
officer so what have you had any
requests that you that you did aside I
guess the the the baby being born one is
pretty odd that's that's pretty odd
that's still probably the weirdest one
but strangely enough I've done four of
them in the last two months really yeah
and now that you're talking about it
more people are probably gonna be late
it's a great idea it's okay I'm all I'm
all for it's good again here's my plug
go to Bruce Buffer calm I'm there please
so now I'll go to Bruce Buffer calm AJ I
want to see what what our options are
it's far what the catalog is yeah yeah
that log is how people do they like look
in the go alright I want you to do this
well here's the one like you can click
um yeah there's the personalized intro
and then it's real simple for $99 you
fill out a simple form bing bang boom it
goes through PayPal and you have it back
in a week and you have you I guess you
have all the equipment at home and you
just bang on your sang out a few a day
yeah just bang them out I banged out
like about twelve before I got on the
plane to Orlando the other day it's good
money that's a nice little side hustle
you know that's not bad we're all about
it's all about how I monetizing your
brand yeah right but in this case I mean
I believe me I've been paid a lot more
nut than that I made a real cheap
because the fans are the MMA UFC fans
are so great and they love their sport
they live eat and breathe the sports I
want to get back to them you know that's
my way of doing it at what point when
you start like I also get part of this
to charity too you do yeah at when your
octagon announcing though at what point
do you decide to turn it into a brand to
turn into a business is that because
when you started did you know your
brother cuz you didn't meet your brother
until you were later in life I know that
story many times yeah we met when I was
basically about twenty nine years old
but I had already been managing his
career for like four years before I got
into the Octagon
so you saw what you can do as in a
answer how you can brand that and turny
it was he doing nothing with it like he
had this great this great announcement
was just not making money off it or not
owning it Michael hadn't even had a
t-shirt or hat with let's get ready
Rumble on and I was at a fight did he
own the phrase yet not when we met and I
used to push him to trade market and
then he did get a trademark out east
here with an attorney but it wasn't
strong enough so when I decided I own
two companies I was making great money
and I lost my passion get back to
passion I was burned out I lost my
passion for what I do I had the beach
house the whole bit just living a great
life but I would get to work or wake up
for work and it's like I hated what I
was doing even though the checks were
substantial so when I was at the riddick
bowe Evander Holyfield fight the first
one yeah Thomas Maxon I think was
November 12th 1993 and I had an epiphany
go off it and it just like let me
dedicate full time to this I wanted to
be his partner his manager and we had a
discussion about it I said listen I'll
sell both companies I'll quit with the
money I have in the bank
I'm going to make you richer more famous
you never dreamed I'm going to roll the
dice here because I could make in the
worst choice of my life and I'm going to
make you in every area sports and
entertainment we're going to trademark
this phrase properly and make video
games and toys and all this he looked at
me like how you gonna do all that
shortened version of so many words sure
as a look if I'm going to give all this
up you better believe I'm going to make
this happen and that was my whole goal
and then when the UFC came on the scene
I my job was to get my client my brother
you know my family member who I loved
dearly
every job I could possibly get him so I
cold called the UFC and I actually got
him to announce UFC six seven and
ultimate ultimate and the very first
show in Casper Wyoming we were having
dinner that night and the owner Robert
meyerwitz who I credit for giving my job
in the Octagon I owe him a lot and I
basically heard him say well Michael
when you get in the Octagon tomorrow
night we want you to say if it's not in
the Octagon it's not real now he's been
doing WCW wrestling right and we have
this huge contract with WCW know where
he does Hulk Hogan and staying in all
those guys I used to bring him in they
used to bring in Michael buffer to just
do the main event exactly and it always
did it made it feel like oh this is a
big stream it made it feel more
legitimate to absolutely' gentlemen hold
it Michael loved that yeah he would do
money night-night rose a whole bit
and and the paycheck was huge and I got
him a real good deal so I knew when he
said that that I was probably gonna get
a call on a Monday lo and behold they
called me on the Monday Bruce what are
you doing
you got him doing this this ultimate
fighting thing and he says that because
this is back in the days when Hulk Hogan
punched you 25 times in the face we
thought it was real or we were supposed
to think it was real because they tried
to make you think it was real was before
sports entertainment and the advertising
behind UFC in the very beginning so way
to die and it's real and it's real with
the implication being don't buy that
wrestling [ __ ] it's fake
this is real they were capitalizing the
whole thing so suddenly you're Abba
cereal so then I lost story cut short I
agreed to only have fulfill was three
fights and honestly Michael could not
have continued on the way the UFC grew
with everything else in his career so
then it was out and I called Robert
Monowitz and I basically said you know
you need a buffer in the Octagon I've
got the media contacts let me I believe
in this and honestly guys from the
beginning even though it's raw and it
was a spectacle I knew was going to be
the biggest thing at fighting sports it
was definitely different than you watch
some of the older ones on the other side
fights [ __ ] I watched an old fight
last again I was just doing last night
it was it was a Alistair Overeem Chuck
Liddell from like 2001 or 2003 [ __ ]
knees to the head on the ground like
things that you just don't see anymore
yeah a brutal but watching uh Mark
Coleman you know dropping head butts and
the people was one of the greatest
things in the world it was amazing to
watch all that stuff but even in the
production value it doesn't it then it
doesn't feel like this is going to be
the phenomenon that it is now no but I
again branding and marketing you know
you have to have a foresight you have to
be able to foresee or think about what
could happen in the future and just like
when I saw my brother and again I just
saw the date November 12th 1999 November
13th 1992 was that really called a bo
Holyfield fight I went back to my room
that night and incessantly wrote three
pages of notes of what I could do with
Michael and that's when it set me myself
out in the goal when I first saw the UFC
come on the scene I knew that with
certain tweaking and rules being refined
and everything else and especially after
I got to go to a couple of the shows
that this literally could be the biggest
thing ever in sports it was the fastest
growing pay-per-view happening at the
time or in history when it came out you
know back then in the beginning they
were doing 250
buys and then you know McCain and all
that process took place and DirecTV and
the Internet kept us alive I stuck with
it you know it's your story when you
believe in something just like when
you're doing your and the Roach coach
motels and the comedy clubs and your
early turnin time of your career you had
to stick with it you knew what's gonna
I'm sure you believed that you were
gonna make it to where you made it I
mean I would hope you just had no other
life skills yeah I think you've both
kind of correct I hope that I would make
it but I really had nowhere else to go
yeah I dropped out of high school left
myself no net I was like I had a law
career to fall back on things like right
well this is the Verrazano Bridge but
when I do that when I do the
motivational stuff in the bottom line is
you either believe in yourself you don't
if you don't believe in yourself when
you knocked on the canvas you're not
gonna have the wherewithal to get up and
fight to get back and be successful some
passion and belief in focus and what do
you think of a ton about you sada and
the drugs and stuff and John Jones is
out for a year and it was just a cialis
it was a dick pill and it seems like a
bit of a harsh punishment knowing that
he wasn't trying to enhance this maybe
it wasn't the smartest move but said the
guy's not cheating he's not no I know
you know we all have our opinions on
that but rules are rules and you know
that until the rules are changed it's
like you know marijuana certainly in my
opinion not a PD right you know
eventually hopefully it'll be taken off
the PD list I don't believe you should
smoke at the night of a fight if night
night before but if you're training all
day and you want to go home and smoke a
fatty that's your choice but do you
think that you shouldn't train you
shouldn't smoke it the night before a
fight and it should be punishable or
just not a smart thing to do well I
think you should still be tested I mean
is in respect to the fighter you're
fighting I don't think you should be
allowed to you know THC up before you go
out for a fight I think you're actually
endangering yourself right or you lie on
the mat like Nick Diaz and put your hand
you know one here and the one your head
in one hand and the lie and look at your
opponent member that fight he had yeah I
was cracking up at that but you know not
saying that that was the case that night
but you know you never know what's going
to take place you're an athlete you're
out there to do your best I saw on your
Twitter are you you're you're an
advocate for marijuana legalization yeah
it's not that I'm not saying I smoke it
right I just there's three things in
life that I believe should be legalized
one is marijuana two is prostitution
it'll never go away I mean even in in
Germany you know it's legal and in other
countries and they do great by it and
the third is online poker and the reason
I say this is because you're a fun guy
that's why you say that
well legalizing these three items which
will never go away will be around
forever you're taking it out of the
hands of the bad guys and respected like
say prostitution
you're cleaning it up you're taking
disease off the street you're you're
basically taxing the hell out of these
three items that will bring a tremendous
amount of income into our government
which we need right
I don't think Trump's going to make this
decision tomorrow but no you know these
are just things it'll never go away so
why not clean them up and make them so
they're righteous are you allowed to
sports gambler because you're involved
with this boy you're not allowed to at
all but I've never been told that I
can't bet on a fight but I do not bet on
fights
I love placing some action on a football
game watching of course I played you
know the poker but I want to go in that
octagon and I want to be an equal
opportunity announcer I don't want to
like even sit down and think whoa I just
put a bet on GSP and maybe I need to
announce him a little loud no that's not
my thing I want to keep it pure and
that's my way of me respecting this
board you got money on one guy so you're
just trying to motivate him with his
introduction Eddie's fighting yeah I
don't know let's just start yeah and I
read the split decision and the winner
off [ __ ] I don't I don't look good in
Vegas about the MGM sports book and I'm
placing a bunch of bets on the USA that
night yeah no I probably wouldn't if I
would tip the odds yeah the the fight is
tomorrow the pay-per-view it's on its
UFC 205 it's from Madison Square Garden
so it's a huge first one here in New
York yeah finally legalized in New York
Mets
that's a mean speaking of legalization
the fact that it took this long for this
state to legalize MMA is absurd well we
I think we all know why you know and
once that politician was out everything
kind of ran smooth very quickly too
quickly
um but the bottom line is this is the
biggest show in history which goes back
to my worry I was trying to tell you
earlier when there's a big show okay I
blew my ACL in Toronto UFC 200 I blew my
ACL before three shows leading up to UFC
hundred and the other knee I am being
very careful until I walk in that
octagon tomorrow night in the garden
guys I'm not gonna I've done all the
press I have to do today I'm gonna go
back finish my five cars play some
online poker at 12 hours asleep ready
for the biggest show of my life where
did you get here today I got here last
night so you want the press conference
Conners I watch this throw a chair and
what a great press conference
mink coat yeah he really is you know you
you people want to see him kill anywhere
they want to see him get knocked the
[ __ ] out he really has a great way of
getting people I vested know he's uh
he's got the 50/50 split or however it
works out people want to see him lose
people and see him win what does it mean
they all buy the pay-per-view yeah yeah
and they did they're talking about him
uh like he's there was articles the
comment came out this week referring to
him as possibly the new ollie just
because of the way he talks up these
fights and it really is funny the way
language has changed because like Ally
like you wouldn't curse but he was
always very combative and now Conor
McGregor walks in there like why were
you late cuz I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
cuz I like he's just I actually mind a
love Connor I love him too I'm not crazy
about that kind of activity I don't you
should be late for press conferences and
all this and and when you say I don't
give a nap it's kind of disrespectful
for the people that do but this is
Connors a lawyer you know here is
walking in you know with a Gucci mink
coat and taking Eddie Alvarez yeah yeah
Eddie had left the stage because he was
like one Conor get you let me know so
you know when Connor walked in he just
went over took Eddie's belt off his side
that's annoying you know the great thing
about Connor is he and Rhonda let's say
there's every every half dozen years or
somebody comes along with what I call
the it factor and Conor McGregor has the
it factor whether he's going to be
better than Muhammad Ali that's a big
task mom is the greatest okay cuz by the
mom and I'll he wasn't just a talker it
was because he was also the greatest
boxer the greatest boxer and you know
there's just so much more about Muhammad
Ali that nobody can even touch but
Connors creating a legacy for himself
and in a legendary status for himself
and let's face it the guy's incredible
and it's incredible to watch him fight
it's incredible to announce him I love
the guy did you hear what he what he how
he responded when Eddie asked him for an
apology no he replied to Eddie that
Eddie could feel free to put his Irish
balls in his mouth yeah I did my big
Irish sack yeah yeah that's what he said
with making their throwing chairs around
the stage I mean I tell you yeah but you
know what people are really loving about
this too is the Dana you know they're
all talking about data just picked him
up with one arm moved them around you
know yeah yeah if the great date is a
tough guy don't don't screw around with
Dana and that's what that's it adds
credibility
when the guy who's in charge is a guy
that looks like he would be a problem
too you know I mean you're not gonna put
some weasel in a suit telling the
fighters what to do nobody wants to
watch that you know um remember back
when Dan was gonna fight Tito Ortiz in a
boxing yes it's like you know I never
thought about that with Don King
especially Bob Arum but that could have
gone out two ways the promoter owner
beats the toughest man in the world say
very much about the guys fighting in the
sport yeah
then Tito beats Dana let's say if it
came out that then it's just like I
think was a lose-lose kind of thing I'm
glad I never happened yes some of those
things are fun in theory but then that
you do the one boxer fighting Adela that
dead men were circus I think this girl
made a big impression at the press
conference right here
Felicia let's listen to her she's a she
beautiful she's a regular girl yeah
appointed in the country of ireland's
what do you think about that don't give
up fuqua Eddie says he's your [ __ ]
Harris how back we've taken back control
in New York see I run New York T a
[ __ ] pimp lucky make without me his
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] chick so good I
wonder what goes on at Dana's head one
of yours and put out a rhyme like that
guy round battle with Nate Diaz in a
short turnaround are you ready for this
fight I'm fresh ready to go I look
forward to I'm gonna shoot this man of
truce me on that I have to imagine you
can hit pause for a second Adrian I have
to imagine that Dana loves this because
this is what this is what got Brazilian
it's on TMZ [ __ ] its people up this
really make people who don't watch the
sport want to know who this [ __ ] is
and why is he doing he has brought
eyeballs to this sport yes that have not
been brought to a Ronda brought female
eyeballs and other eyeballs to the sport
when I walk around and and the talk that
I get from people and people I know that
never even watched the UFC and they're
talking to me about Conor McGregor
that's a game changer Conor McGregor is
a game changer he's a household name and
there's not that many household names I
said a while back that he will be the
first fighter in UFC to earn a hundred
million dollars and Wow and then I
remembered that Lorenzo Fertitta came
out and said the same thing a week or so
later and I right now I think the figure
is almost at forty is easily going to be
at one
million by the end of I would say not
next year but the year after 2080 spent
quite a bit I don't know Connor burrows
I hear he has quite a fun life as we got
to be careful but you know I think it'll
make expensive because he said he's got
a mink coat you wonder if he bought that
if it's just on loan you hope did you
hear that well I did because he had the
tags hanging from it when he walked in
our says he goes you rented that guy
receipt in the pocket on his prophet I'm
ready to run Connors making so much
money I would venture to guess that
aside from you know I I don't see him I
see him spending a lot of money on
clothes yeah his flash and his bling um
but hopefully unlike other athletes that
we seen let's face it 85% of go broke
five years after they retire I hope that
is not happened to Connor he's making so
much money you got to be an idiot to
spend that much money but honestly like
the money that he spends on clothes is
an investment in that like you know you
want to think that a fighter is just
going to get paid strictly for the
performance in the Octagon but the fact
of the matter is part of him getting as
many eyes as he gets on the show and
being responsible for as many
pay-per-view buys as he is is that flash
factor no question but you know again we
get back to branding okay he's branding
himself this is his brand yeah stop with
that he gets into New York and he has
two rolls-royce's one with his name on
it you know where on the car is his name
it's right under Tory us right on the
whole side of the car he's driving it
always a little subtle by Conahan oh no
I thought it was a personalized play
right there there it is oh you got a
rolls-royce and put his face on it
yeah put his face on this his face is
all over the back door it says notorious
see it right there Wow
so across the entire it's the it's the
left side of the car across the entire
side of the card says the word notorious
and then there is a giant Conor McGregor
face right at the back of the of the
back that's bad that's bad though
because everyone's gonna know it's you
you know how much I would hate that by
face on the side of my car like why is
Jim Norton riding around the same block
all right let me tell you a couple
things why why I respect Conor
McGregor's so much you know back in I
think it was Dublin I did a show years
ago right and this young like nineteen
year old kid comes up to me no beard
he goes my name is Conor McGregor
remember it you're going to be
announcing me someday
okay okay great I get that all the time
right the guy had the fortitude and the
foresight to get to worry he believes in
himself that confidence we were talking
confidence factor is huge and Connor is
a very intelligent young man
he's sharp you know that he's not so
much rehearsed as as others like I think
she'll son was a great trash talker but
he's rehearsed yeah he's not rehearsed I
mean jailson was literally doing the
rest the pro-wrestling promise that he
saw when he was a kid his brain and he's
bringing into the octa he was great yeah
but that's what he was doing we really
were hurt you didn't even feel rehearse
today I guess I just didn't catch the
really great sure yeah I guarantee that
a few of those lines at a child's mouth
were practice the night before I have no
doubt about you can find them on YouTube
like that like on the wrestlers that did
them in the 70s not taking anything way
from chill because chose brilliant what
he did but Connor brings that whole it's
it's like everything goes to a next
level Connors the next level yeah he
just announced the Irish were taking
back New York like it was Gangs of New
York
I've never heard a fighter threaten to
say to put your bag in somebody else's
mouth yeah let's listen to some more
that Prescott really great it was really
awesome my questions ready questions
ready Alvarez acha Bieber said that he
helps you win the fight so if you won't
dock them if you win do you have any any
ideas on what's next for you if you do
be Connor after I beat Connor and
silence that come to your Island I'll
have a couple pina coladas you ought to
look for me somewhere Eddie does a good
job but it's so hard to match confident
yeah yeah is there any truth to the idea
that you want to retire after this fight
or gonna take time off
I'm only warming up only having up he's
going to have to all damn belts I'll
take all damn belts over there it's it's
hilarious moving weight class to weight
class everybody it's weird because I'm
watching this I like Eddie Alvarez a lot
so I kind of want to see him really
flatten you do oh yeah I just don't want
to sad stupid I don't want I don't want
the talking to stop ever what the
talking will never stop he lost an idea
as the talk shop now I took a point
you're dealing with the toughest
fighting arena in the world the proving
ground of Champions beyond any other
ring or square ring or whatever is the
octagon for fires okay
not the boxes aren't fighters they're
boxing these are fighters getting in
they're using every form of fighting
there is it's just that's what it is we
we got to let you go but before we do
because you get a Big Damn press Bruce
Buffer but Frank in the Bronx has a
question for you what's going on Frank
ease everybody oh yeah now Frank
hey guys Bruce a pleasure to talk to you
I just got back from Vegas last night I
was at the MGM but I was thinking about
you take any concept of your brother's
you know let's get ready to rumble
and incorporating it many years ago what
first of all what made you think of
doing that and how happy is your brother
the fact that you know you did that and
never thought about it so long ago and
last but not least uh I think you're a
little bit better than your brother now
you're hungry and you sound like Paula
McGregor oh thank you for that I
appreciate it I want you to baby I want
you to say your brother lucky would take
you out but I had you know my brother to
me is legendary the greatest announcer
of all time I mean he set the pace and
and brought the attention to the ring
announcer in the square circle of boxing
and you know I respect that and then
when I saw the let's get ready to rumble
I was actually a fan of this man before
I ever met him and when they put his
name on the screen during the fights I
was like what is going on here because
we didn't have the internet back then we
had phone books and I never saw my name
in a phone book as we all naturally
would do back then so I was a huge fan
when I met him and I just saw so much
greatness there that could be put into
every form of sports and entertainment
that I wanted to get behind it and just
help direct his career and take him to
the level he has gotten to and beyond
and it's really just a passionate smart
move business-wise a passionate move
because of my half-brother Michael
buffer and loving my brother the way I
do and in our family and it's just yeah
I just set out to get it done well UFC
205 is tomorrow night 10 p.m. from
Madison Square Garden it's on
pay-per-view our tickets still available
or just made some they just made some
tickets available really I read
yesterday there they just may I don't
know where they are but it was an
article I read it said take some more
tickets have been made available so
check
it's wrong I was hitting no check MSG
check ticketron but I've heard Wow did
these tickets octagon side are going for
five to fifteen thousand on the scalpers
amazing and this this show I'm sure
people know but before they went on sale
to the public this was sold out at three
hours on a pre-sale yeah it's like one
of the fastest not the fastest selling
events ever and gonna be the
highest-grossing event at Madison Square
Garden is yet if it did sellout and in
presale another some tickets that I
don't know what happened sometimes I
think people have certain Compson
they're not going to use they just some
spacing that they say maybe maybe move
videotron you know make another hundred
seats available I mean who knows but
they never you guys never work Madison
Square Garden before so you don't know
you know the exact exact exact
dimensions before you get there well
this speaking never working before this
is the biggest show in the history of
the UFC this is the pinnacle for the UFC
in the United States of America is the
pinnacle night tomorrow night for my
career walking out in the garden you
know the most famous arena in the world
I'm just jack guys so I'm I'm I might
blow I wish I had a third ACL I want to
blow another one buds appendicitis but
that's right there's always you're
growing there's other things you can
injure don't say grind gym no let's hope
you maintain I mean watch the paper you
just to see if Bruce Buffer can maintain
all is all his faculties yeah there we
go
who knows who knows what's going to
happen Dana Dan if you're listening I'd
like 10 cents a buy please thank you
very much Bruce Buffer you can also
follow Bruce Buffer on Twitter at Bruce
Buffer and you can go to Bruce Buffer
comm if you want to get any of the
custom intros thank you for anything
like that
and we'll take a break yeah I'm going to
piss all right you go piss and we'll be
back with more Jim Norton
thanks guys are great I appreciate it
thanks